meine sehr geehrten damen und herren sie
alle wissen dass alexej nawalny am 22
august mit vergiftungserscheinungen aus
russland kommend zur ärztlichen
behandlung nach berlin geflogen wurde
auf veranlassung und auf bitten der
charité universitätsmedizin berlin hat
ein speziallabor der bundeswehr
eine toxikologische untersuchung anhand
von proben von herrn navalny
durchgeführt hierbei das ist das
ergebnis wurde der zweifelsfreie
nachweis eines chemischen nerven
kampfstoffes der novitec gruppe erbracht
das institut für pharmakologie und
toxikologie der bundeswehr ist eine
ressortforschungseinrichtung im
geschäftsbereich des
bundesverteidigungsministeriums es dient
als deutsches kompetenzzentrum für den
medizinischen schutz vor chemischen
waffen und ist definiertes labor der
organisation für das verbot chemischer
waffen vcw und die arbeit dieses labors
und das ziel der arbeit dieses instituts
ist der medizinische schutz der menschen
in deutschland zivilisten und
soldatinnen und soldaten vor
gefährlichen chemie waffen
wir sind uns in der bundesregierung
einig gewesen auch nach unserem treffen
heute das ist ein bestürzen der vorgang
ist dass alexej nawalny in russland
opfer eines angriffes mit einem
chemischen nerven kampfstoff geworden
ist
unsere gedanken sind vor allen dingen
bei ihm und seiner familie und wir und
ich wünsche ihm baldige und vollständige
genesung
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
aufgrund dieser neuen erkenntnisse hat
die bundesregierung heute nachmittag
russischen botschafter erneut zu einem
dringenden gespräch ins auswärtige amt
eingeladen
ihm wurden dabei nochmals
unmissverständlich die aufforderung der
bundesregierung übermittelt
die hintergründe dieser nun
nachweislichen vergiftungen von alexei
navalny vollumfänglich und in voller
transparenz aufzuklären wir wissen jetzt
dass es ein angriff mit einem chemischen
nerven kampfstoff gegeben hat umso
dringlicher ist es nun dass auch in
russland die verantwortlichen ermittelt
und zur rechenschaft gezogen werden
wir verurteilen diesen angriff auf das
allerschärfste wir werden nun auch
unverzüglich unsere partner in der
europäischen union und der nato auf den
dafür vorgesehenen kanälen informieren
und über die neuen erkenntnisse ins bild
setzen wir werden mit ihnen in den
nächsten tagen darüber beraten wie wir
in europa darauf angemessen reagieren
können
darüber werden wir auch im lichte dessen
entscheiden wie russland sich nun
verhält
wir werden auch die organisation für das
verbot chemischer waffen die vcw in den
haag über die toxologischen
untersuchungsergebnisse informieren
denn das chemiewaffen übereinkommen
verbietet jeden einsatz chemischer
waffen und auch die fraktionen des
deutschen bundestages haben wir
unverzüglich informiert russland sollte
selbst ein ernsthaftes interesse haben
einen guten beziehungen zu seinen
nachbarn in europa spätestens nun ist
der zeitpunkt einen entscheidenden
beitrag dazu zu leisten
wir hoffen weiterhin auf eine
vollständige und weitere genesung von
alexei navalny